un thème de la sécurité dans les
établissements scolaires qui vous fait
réagir selon notre question web vous
êtes 74 % à souhaité l'installation de
portique et de caméra 9 % le recrutement
de surveillant enfin 17 % d'entre vous
estim qu'il est bien difficile de
sécuriser chaque établissement autre
mesures pris par le gouvernement après
ce drame d'aras la France est passée en
alerte urgence attentat ou alors
qu'est-ce que cela signifie concrètement
en indrloir il y a-t-il des individus
radicalisés et surveillés dans notre
appartement trois questions au préfet
Patrice Latron
[Musique]
écoutez j'ai donné des instructions aux
forces de l'ordre dès vendredi d'être
extrêmement présente aux abords des
établissement ces instructions sont
toujours en vigueur ce cette semaine
nous y avons travaillé ce weekend une
réunion d'urgence a été organisée samedi
après-midi il y a 7000 militaires
supplémentaires 7000 militaires au total
qui sont déployés depuis ce matin
partout en France France j'ai fait des
demandes toutes ne sont pas satisfaites
bah car évidemment les 20 départements
de la zone de défense Ouest ont fait des
demandes également en revanche nous
allons avoir un
renforcement dans les jours qui viennent
dans sentinelle et donc nous sommes en
train de travailler à aux modalités du
déploiement de ces militaires
[Musique]
supplémentaires c'est une présence
concentrée sur des secteurs d'activité
particuliers encore une fois je
rentrerai pas dans les détails mais on
en a parlé les établissements scolaires
font partie des des établissements sur
lesquels des forces de l'ordre
concentrent leur action les les lieux de
culte
également culte juif le culte catholique
et le culte musulman ça fait partie des
endroits sur lesquels dans des moments
de tension comme celui que nous
connaissons les forces de l'ordre sont
beaucoup plus attentives les forces de
l'ordre sont pleinement mobilisées pas
que sur les établissements scolaires je
ne rentrerai pas dans les détails mais
il y a un certain nombre de mesures qui
sont confidentielles qui sont prises
dans le cadre du plan Vigipirate et
encore une fois c'est l'affaire de tous
donc ne pas laisser traîner des sacs
observer les comportements suspects et
savoir rendre compte soit à la
communauté éducative soit aux forces de
[Musique]
l'ordre le sujet n'est pas tant dans le
dénombrement du nombre de fichesse le
sujet c'est de renforcer le suivi des
individus dangereux que l'on connaît et
donc comme partout en France demain je
vais avec le procureur de la République
présider un groupe un Jed un groupe
d'études départemental sur des gens qui
sont beaucoup plus dangereux que les
fichiers ce sont les gens qui sont
inscrits au
fsprt des personnes suspectes ou
radicalisé et là je serais amené très
probablement à prendre des mesures
contre ces personnes puisque le ministre
de l'Intérieur nous demande d'être
extrêmement ferme de rebalayer la liste
de C quelques dizaines de personnes en
indr etloir et de déterminer quelles
mesures administrativ ou judiciaire nous
pourrons prendre à leur
égard